love your neighbor as yourself
do not worry about tomorrow
for tomorrow we'll worry about itself
each day has enough trouble of its own
man does not live on bread alone
but on every word that comes from the
mouth of God
who of You by worrying can add a single
hour to his life
let your light shine before men
that they may see your good deeds and
praise your father in Heaven
so in everything do to others what you
would have them do to you
Whoever has the will be given more
whoever does not have
even what he has will be taken from him
why do you look at the speck of sawdust
in your brother's eye
and pay no attention to the plank in
your own eye
only in his hometown among his relatives
and in his own house
is a prophet without honor
love your enemies
do good to those who hate you
bless those who curse you
pray for those who mistreat you
do not judge
where you too will be judged
give to everyone who asks you
and if anyone takes what belongs to you
do not demand it back
if you forgive men when they sin against
you
your heavenly father will also forgive
you
make a tree good and its fruit will be
good
make a tree bad and its fruit will be
bad
for a tree is recognized by its fruit
be careful not to do your acts of
righteousness before men to be seen by
them
no one can serve two masters
either he will hate the one and love the
other
or he will be devoted to the one and
despise the other
nothing outside a man can make him
unclean by going into him
rather it is what comes out of a man
that makes him unclean
you are the salt of the earth
but if the salt loses its saltiness
how can it be made salty again
it is no longer good for anything
except to be thrown out and trampled by
men
watch out for false prophets
they come to you in sheep's clothing
but inwardly they are ferocious wolves
ask and it will be given to you
seek and you will find
knock and the door will be opened to you
do not worry about your life
what you will eat or drink or about your
body
what you will wear
isn't life more important than food and
the body more important than clothes
what is impossible with men
is possible with God
come to me
all you who are weary and burdened
and I will give you rest
watch out
be on your guard against all kinds of
greed
a man's life does not consist of the
abundance of his possessions
but when you pray
go into your room
close the door and pray to your father
who is unseen
then your father who sees what is done
in secret
will reward you
we have collected these quotes by Jesus
of Nazareth who has said so much
regarding our lives and the eternal life
to come as the Son of God he was sent to
Earth for that very purpose we hope you
enjoyed this video
thanks for watching